I do want to focus in a little bit on
one more specific component of the trunk
Putin summit and press conference and it
centers around compromising material the
entire press conference was a gong show
of Donald Trump basically being
subjugated by Putin but being the beta
to Putin's alpha and it was embarrassing
in every way I hesitate to use the
c-word I know people don't like it but
the guy was cocked the guy was cocked I
don't know how else to say it and at the
end of the press conference Putin was
asked straight up
do you have compromising material on
Trump whether it's the PP tapes of the
steel dossier Fame or something else and
Vladimir Putin very coy Lee did not deny
it and let's listen to Putin's answer of
course through a live translator and now
to the compromising material yeah I did
heard rumors we allegedly collected
compromising material on mr. Trump when
he was visiting Moscow fingers call it
let me tell you this when President
Trump visit Moscow back then I didn't
even know that he was in Moscow I treat
present Trump with utmost respect but
back then when he was a private
individual a businessman nobody told me
that he was in Moscow let's take you st.
Petersburg economic forum for instance
over 500 American businessman the high
rank in the high-level ones I don't even
remember which the last names of each
and every one of them well do you
remember do you think that we try to
collect compromising material on each
and every single one of them well it's
difficult to imagine another nonsense of
a bigger scale than this well please
just disregard these issues and don't
think about this anymore again so not a
single denial putin asked do you have
compromising material on trump he says I
didn't know Trump was in Moscow at the
time in question
I respect Trump I heard about the rumor
about compromising material I wasn't
informed that Trump was in Moscow there
were lots of other businessmen here as
well and I don't know all of their names
it would be tough to collect damaging
material on all of those people and
please disregard and don't think about
this anymore not denials and the
question is is Putin playing coy because
he wants to be vague about whether he
as the stuff or and I if this occurred
to me this morning Pat when we were
talking about it is it possible that
Putin is playing coy
because even Trump himself doesn't know
whether Putin has the material is it
possible that Trump knows he did do
something in Russia which if it were
filmed would be embarrassing but he
genuinely doesn't know if it was
recorded
yeah and Putin knowing that Trump
doesn't know can take advantage of that
situation - exactly right just another
possibility and then maybe the most
bizarre moment of the entire thing and
there were many this answer from Putin
seemed to panic Donald Trump and he
immediately what we're gonna play for
you the 24 seconds we're about to play
for you happened right after what you
just heard Trump responds with a very
strange tirade about FBI agent Peters
Strock a move that seems to like totally
reflexive panic from Trump take a look
it would have been out long ago and if
anybody watched Peter struck testify
over the last couple of days and I was
in Brussels watching it it was a
disgrace to the FBI it was a disgrace to
our country and you would say that was a
total witch hunt thank you very much
everybody
thank you
[Music]
what does Peter stock have to do with
this it's just I guess an opportunity to
attack the FBI and those last 10 seconds
kind of sum up the entire thing absolute
and total irrational panic by Trump
combined with what about ISM so long
story short no denial from Putin that
they have compromising material Putin
may be playing coy maybe Putin reminding
Trump that he'd better behave send me
your thoughts about what is a very very
strange moment I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and it is a very very full
day of news today today's program is
made possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman this is something I really
believe in better help gives you access
to fully licensed and experienced
psychologists and therapists through
your phone or computer I have been
talking for years about the problem
around people not seeking help because
of the stigma around mental health
services because of the cost of mental
health services and all you have to do
with better help is go to better help
calm slash Pakman answer some basic
questions you'll be matched with a
therapist that will be right for you
you can change therapists if you don't
think that it's a good fit it's less
expensive than seeing someone in person
you will still get the professional help
and it is unlimited you can talk to a
therapist every day from home or
wherever you are go to better help calm
slash Pakman it is so easy to sign up
and get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube better help calm slash PA que ma
n if you've been wanting to talk to
somebody but for whatever reason haven't
please go to better help calm slash PA
que ma N